[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about hello friends
yeah you're back and we're so happy to
have you back thank you guys
it's good to be here are we the first
group that you hang out with
since quarantine yes how does it feel it
feels good I was really looking forward
to it
when Bart hitting me up he was like I'm
gonna follow up with you the week of
just to make sure it's still good cuz
the last time I wife was cool and then
as it came close she was like I know
right from under me like oh yeah and I
was like oh here I thought y'all was
gonna hit me back
no oh they will annoyingly but it was
good when you're a favorite your [ __ ]
people
I'm glad yeah so I was happy when I was
on the way here I was like 20 more
minutes were you thinking about what if
they hugged me like what do I do [ __ ] I
was waiting for the hug listen this
might not be popular but it's gonna be a
little weird to come out of a pandemic
we're almost certainly gonna have
another spike I don't think we're gonna
go back into like a quarantine again
we're just gonna have to like deal with
it and and I think that's just gonna be
yes like I think we're just bad mist
hogs man yeah I like hugging people I
like being with people I like parties
restaurants I see my friends we're
talking Buress
yeah it's always like an awkward like
[ __ ] it and then we had the CDC said if
you're nice with the medic you're good
but you could be asymptomatic alright
remember they just changed Italy I just
changed it I've had some secret hugs
with people but I won't say who they
might be in this room right now did you
go to a barber yet your beard is looking
or so well here's the thing barbers open
on the second oh my la standards I
actually waited the entire time but I
did pay my barber the whole time though
I wouldn't it even
I paid my barber the whole time as if he
was cutting me my kid cuz I mean that's
like well my barber is my life yeah like
I knew he was down bad you know saying
he can't get no cuts my kids grew froze
well my once I've already had to throw
my other kid grew a fro but as soon as
barbershops opened up he came in and cut
my beard and it was great I actually
miss my beer completely up
oh [ __ ] like I named like you he does
house calls for you yeah oh damn her
celebrity man no I'm just lazy dude I
had to cut my way to like I think if you
get a work as hard as we do right and
you're gonna have the resources you
should have some things an opportunity
clauses that cost from the career house
- that's way extra weight so LA is
already the most expensive haircut right
ever like in Tacoma where I live a
haircut was $12 okay so in the Barbara
here at the shop was $30 so how it's
already pretty expensive it's very
expensive and then what's hip it's 40 to
50 right cuz you got to take care of it
that's every two weeks
whoa every week for me oh so you're
sorry but you're trying to avoid the
question but it's 100 200 300
well the way I do it
well it's really two people so I stagger
it so I get a line up with one of my son
gets a haircut in the next week I get a
lot of the other son gets but you always
get but I always get the line up and
that's tight because I'm paying for you
to come to me that's more of a cost like
I just I don't want to go to the
barbershop and and be there for like two
and a half hours that's just and it's
just a whole thing man I just don't got
a barber chair in the house no I do get
like an amazing mansion I would do that
because Ron house LeBron has an actual
barber chair and multiple so him and his
homies and you cut at the seams and
those are
yeah yeah well you wanna give me chair
you don't have a game my kids really mad
about Mike is a peon oldest son was
really took offense to that appropriate
gaming culture don't think I'm cool you
don't get cool stuff you can't
appropriate gamer okay it's just a
comfortable chair like I do all these
zoom causes make sure you getting a
barber chair be like what is a
comfortable chair why that's me and an
Indian Robin like this is comfortable
I'll have you know dude I can't believe
you had partners coming your house
I had to meanwhile cut my hair with my
ball hair trimmer yeah I'd use my man's
cape on I actually was impressed cuz I
did a good job I thought he did a good
job he was a little patchy but at least
like it was like the right it was even
you know it was just patched all [ __ ]
blow your skills are that's how bad my
dress yeah it was patchy but still I was
so surprised
yeah but we're all used to being patchy
so like he caught the right places
good job Steve it's like he like used
coloring right and he made the sky blue
the little Sun it was like all the way
though and he's like this is a zigzaggy
like to color it made the in birds yeah
yeah she holds my dick when I pee too
because otherwise I get it all over the
place you know it's funny about that I
this is weird but we're here now I'm
right-handed but I pee with my left hand
I'm right-handed I masturbate with my
left hand
really yeah I think you just it's more
comfortable to pee with my left eye I
thought everybody did that and people
are my boys I talked about with him
because like if you need this hand to do
other things yes I always pee with my
left and I thought it was like the only
thing I'm good at with my left hand
why would you do all this really yeah I
thought that that joke yes you hold his
dick what am I pee sitting down a lot
and I would believe that it's like a
bart trust me have you ever done it you
should try and see how hard it is
because you guys always get mad at us
for like people let's see okay but
here's what you don't understand you
don't when it first comes out you don't
know how much what straight what
pressure you masculine I sit down I sit
down four-foot stream and sometimes very
too far from the toilet have you guys
ever tried to turn on a garden hose yeah
so you turn it on right if we just watch
it yep the hose does this obviously you
don't do that you some weird place a
woman you wanna try it now YouTube
challenge holding my boyfriend's penis
why he put the camera on the toilet see
how well you do also the penis during
different times of the day with the
boner has different flaccid isset ease
sometimes it's like mm-hmm
and so it's like so you don't know what
to expect at any time yeah there's been
some times you have to pee you like you
have a physics a you have like a if
you're hard
you got a pee really bad you've got it
like pee up and inhabit parabola like
you have to make it come down into the
toilet so far you can push it down it
hurts I don't care like okay you're very
skilled right so I'm like whatever he
takes a lot and I don't I have never
lived that experience do but afterwards
you see pee on the toilet [ __ ] clean
it up in no that's where I got nothing
for you there yeah okay guys do that I
into your own piss if I pee on the rim
bites really get a mic like that and I
and I why I do that but I think that I
shouldn't get a medal for it either
that's right Dana practice we have
separate bathrooms so I'll have to see
this really do you clean your own
bathroom yeah the other housekeeper well
we were starting to have a service come
all over once every couple of weeks but
and the pandemic happened yeah we had to
stop to you yeah the worst part is
putting your clothes away yes thank you
oh it's the best part if your clothes
and putting the weigh-in fan in matching
socks when kids can somebody make a
sorter so we just throw our clothes in
there and then it sorts them and puts it
away a premium for that there's a thing
we did taking these on eight years ago
oh yeah they do have like a washing
machine thingy or no a folding machine
thingy where you put your laundry in and
then it just folds it for you and well
what is it like it's not a Best Buy or
nothing no yeah no mainstream thing it's
like an invention that has been invented
but it's not like mass-produced here's
like right now cause 88 grand sorry
everybody we're working on a huge dinner
we just basically be wearing sweats and
t-shirts so that has been like he's
basically we're the same thing every day
that's my problem I'm gonna bring this
up this is 20 minutes right yeah here's
what I realized you wear underwear right
you wash those you put them back on the
top you just keep wearing the same
underwear like you put them back on the
top of your drawer you gotta like makes
your underwear that's what I do
what do you mean like you see all your
underwear it's like it's like a like a
files so it goes like this right and
then you take this one out and then when
you refill it you go yeah and then it
comes forward just blow your mind
I just put mine on the top and then I
wear and then like some will be like
completely new bottom and the rest of
like there's other people that gets
stressed out from underwear then if you
experience stress or have anxiety
chronic pain from bending over from
organizing all your laundry or if you
just can't sleep that's yeah feels is a
premium CBD delivered directly to your
doorstep and what this feels do feels
naturally helps reduce stress anxiety
pain and sleeplessness a few little
drops under your tongue and you feel the
difference within minutes the fina
remember about CVD is that finding your
right dose is important so leave room an
experiment over the course of a week or
so and you may need to take more or less
to get the effects you're
after new to CBD fields also offers a
free CVD hotline to help you guide your
personal experience in case you feel
scared or feel weird about you can call
them and feels works naturally to help
you feel better there's no hi hangover
or addiction join the fields community
get fields delivered to your door every
month you'll save money on every order
and you can possible cancel anytime
exactly so become a member today by
going to feels calm slash off the record
and you'll get 50% off your first order
with free shipping
that's s.e.a.l.s calm / off the record
and become a member and get 50% off
automatically taking off your first
order with free shipping once again
feels dot-com / off the record masterful
transition looks great win a [ __ ]
Internet Award is your job back to peace
flashing with your dick
take some CBD and stop doing that y'all
never pee hard and that's why water gets
on your blood well you girls don't do
that sounds like it's really hot it's
laughing bounces back is it when I'm
taking a [ __ ] sometimes and it's pretty
Duggar it's like hey that's what I'm
thinking of that's the only time like
that with actual pee though or sometimes
like with the pee the stream will come
out all weird and then I'll end up
getting like oh it's a crooked yeah yeah
you're so like yeah like kind of like
undercarriage yeah like while you're on
the toilet yes she forgot to spread it
first
I never surprise sit on the toilet this
way oh yeah seen the face in the back
just getting some work done
we got a laptop already bear I love
going to the bathroom man [ __ ] yes
especially when you got kids dude it is
so one hour you - Oh gross - eat while
you're gonna [ __ ] yeah I can't even take
you into the bathroom bathroom era you
could do it anywhere disgusting you had
something nice trash goes I would never
have white cheddar cheese it's what I
don't she likes to keep a certain level
of food in her says it's coming ash
likes to read the ballot it might be
dropping that way the only time I've
ever bathroom is if I'm taking a bath
and I'm like eating some like
strawberries I'm sorry but it's weird
when you're warm you're fine that's what
I was doing in your bathroom there's a
couple of others am i no control yeah
you have no control
aha you remember middle school middle
school is a crazy time penis was on
steroids my man whether you've got a
book report talked about right now for
the whole class I want to be a part of
it the bell rings and you know why right
now everyone standing over all leaving
god damn I used to have to put my
backpack like hold my backpack in front
of me keep a book out just in case it
was ridiculous yeah they like took it
into their boxers tucked it in the
boxers a lot yeah biltong it's it was a
whole thing man yeah yeah it was tough
not until we started talking about it
here on Jay King years a few years ago
is when I discovered like it popped in
my head like oh my god that's why guys
always had the binders yes you yes more
like they would like wrap their shirt
sweater around I'm like isn't it like
why you have the sweater it's kind of
hot why are you really doing it for just
the next like 30 minutes yeah
I never thought about dude I had a buddy
who used to be like yo dude look look at
my look at my pants right now
and then he would make his dick he would
twitch his dick and make the pants go up
and I'm like dude it's not a magic trick
if I know how the trick is done that was
when you know we're at that right age
we're just getting buff like serious
boners and [ __ ] like can you wiggle your
ears type of thing yeah exactly
but he thought it was like a cool trick
and I'm like it is a cool trick though
but it's like magician to magician it's
not as cool though right yeah man okay
he's coming on to you boss do you want
to touch it Steve if you get a move I
don't know well my friend used to touch
guys dicks and be like look it's a magic
trick done like make it go up like at
school she'd be like watch in like a
girl yeah girl
so we liked her they were all consensual
guys dude was a chick that all that
there was a chick in my school would
charge five dollars and you could feel
her boobs
what yeah dude what an entrepreneur
would she ballin only fans I don't know
if she was volatile that was what a
bunch of users are doing that now we
might not go back to the club's yeah
well you always know you need to go back
to the doll I'm sorry I agree you can
hit you can get more out of a person in
person absolutely
like you like strippers can make you
feel like it's just used by 200 300 400
you might not be able to get that same
thing over web but the subscription
model if you get like amount of
subscribers that Netflix has it might be
better overall
the strippers might not want to go back
shivers might not go back stripper
economy new people they're the only ones
keeping cash currency alive I don't know
how your money longer zipper you know
what it'll be is if VR takes off then
they won't need stripper stripper clubs
anymore because like a few it looks like
she's standing really you probably don't
cuz you don't need you don't need to be
in the room during porn
board what lap is it
imagine how much better that would be
different porn with VR man well they do
have that already do they yeah and like
you could look like real cool I don't
want that like I wouldn't know no they
haven't shaved a long time yeah
KJ the lights off in here yeah be like
perfect
oh yeah I forgot that was your thing
that is my opinion yep I don't like
seeing razor bumps and Bart is
consistently perfect so shows your hands
Bart oh they're gone just drying them
for a second gloves all day rings Oh big
as he set his hands right are the bumps
there I know that these ones heal pretty
good I got [ __ ] you don't tell another
thing you can already show your
different eyes it's only been a day know
what you're talking about
I've been not gonna wear for a week now
videos catch up on bars hands catch up
what don't catch up that's such a dad
joke Oh your kids too you said there's
ketchup on ya cuz we all had french
fries at lunch
oh we whipped ketchup you've been
killing it with the dead jokes
I love dead jokes I love like the bat
okay I'm gonna be honest with you just
cuz we're friends
I don't like jokes I just really like
with you yeah and it's so [ __ ]
genuine that I'm like I love the joke
now yes you make me love the joke I did
that's why I try to only pick ones that
really make me laugh like I can't fake
it I have to really like you've been
stupid I'll be laughing at oh yeah only
you can make it oh my god Sally anyone
else say myself
they suck that's what I said about
Steve's delivery before and I meant it
exactly like that that your laugh is
contagious but when you are sometimes
you deliver it and you're laughing at
the joke as you're delivering it and it
makes me laugh and I like it's a
contagious thing but you got offended
oh yeah your Froyo Steve oh yeah for
hell he we're all comedian made a glass
oh yeah you thought I was saying that
the joke wasn't funny that it was people
were only laughing cuz he was laughing
but I was like no
was an ego first response yeah she said
- yeah I knew I have no problem dad
jokes I love dad jokes yeah it's funny
because I actually got a brand deal with
Laffy Taffy because of them no I wasn't
even using it I was just making out oh
those were yeah yeah yeah for a Brando's
I was using no but I thought you were
using them and then you got the brand
deal that's why I got like Sean cool I
was just making him up or taking them
off the internet and Laffy Taffy will I
didn't know let me tap me on social
media they'll hit me up man what and
free candy it was great I want to ask
you this are you so your as a comedian
but also / youtuber person your brand is
keV on stage have you ever thought like
like timothydelaghetto shed his his last
name and just took his last name I'm
just going back to my phone so no I
never thought about it because keV
my keV is in the name like camp on stage
is just like for a lot of you that's my
name baby my name is Kevin yeah yeah
exactly
no but the only reason I actually went
by Kevin on stage because I was working
at a bank and people were getting fired
for their tweets and my name was Kevin
Frederick's on Twitter and Facebook and
I was like man if I get fired there I
won't at least make it hard for them to
find me so I changed the cab on stage
because I was doing stand-up and then I
just made my YouTube page all that and
now it's when they call you up on stage
they say now up to the stage keV on
stage oh no my name I thought that was
just your handle no it is people called
me keV on stage like my name is Kevin
stick but if I'd like do movies like if
I were to get cast in a real movie I
would go back
Kevin Frederick's something like that
but Tammuz was like his became
problematic and people didn't understand
and and the more he had to explain it
the older The Fresh Prince got the more
people didn't get it so it was the whole
thing but camelus age is just a nickname
Plus on stage you know in movies and
stuff you would do your full name yeah
we'll go by Kevin fortress that's cool
I was like jenna Marbles no one calls
her by her last there's your last names
Maury Oh
yeah let's see that's like such oh
that's like herb Baker brand yeah that's
her personality like I think I knew her
name and it didn't mean click like jenna
Marbles is who she is but at least her
real name is Jenna yeah
[Music]